we've seen the new budget that Donald
Trump wants it would cut money for meals
on wheels and it would add money to pay
for that Mexican wall that he insisted
Mexico was going to pay for if you've
never heard of meals on wheels it's a
program that delivers meals to people at
home who are either unable to buy or
unable to prepare their own meals
the name is sort of used generically to
refer to a lot of different home
delivered meals programs not all of
which are officially meals on wheels but
this is one program which the government
does fund Donald Trump's budget
blueprint for the next fiscal year
indicates that he will eliminate the
three billion dollar Community
Development Block Grant program which
pays for meals on wheels as well as
other programs and will be funding the
US Mexican border wall initially with
1.5 billion dollars and then a
subsequent 2.6 billion if his spending
plans are approved for the 2018 budget
year cutting meals to seniors as well as
cutting WIC women with infant children I
mean programs that who could possibly be
against these programs cutting funding
to those programs to build a wall with
Mexico that won't even do what Trump
promises it will do and that Trump said
Mexico would pay for legal and heating
aid for poor people by National
Endowment for the Arts goodbye the
Environmental Protection Agency will
also see its funding reduced which makes
sense because the guy running it doesn't
even really think that it's an
organization that should exist and let
me again remind you that aside from it
being insane to cut these programs and
adding funding for the wall Trump is
talking about 4.1 billion the wall is
going to cost by some estimates twenty
two billion dollars what is the four
billion even going to do it's not even
going to fund a fraction of what it
would cost to build this wall I mean
honestly the remainder could go to
adding to the national debt I have run
some other numbers because we're only
scratching the surface here when it
comes to the budget cuts yeah so I took
out my abacus in my protractor and
everything else please and I saw the
EPA's gonna cut 31% yeah State
Department 29%
agriculture 21% 21 percent but the
Defense Department is getting a nine
percent rates oh how nice even though we
are spending the most amount on defense
compared to not the next nine countries
combined right currently we need more oh
absolutely we always need more gotta
have a strong military we're gonna win
and we're gonna you know other people
will lose and all that stuff when this
is formally released it's time to call
your representatives if you vote for
this budget if you use my tax money for
the wall I will vote you out I would
like to believe okay that even the most
committed Trumpets believes that we
should fund WIC women with infant
children funding for women with single
women with infant children as the name
says that we should fund
Meals on Wheels I don't know if I will
be vindicated my faith in humanity Pat
makes me believe that all trumpets word
say let's not cut those programs but
some probably would want to cut those
programs
perhaps I mean I think a majority of
Republicans support keeping the federal
funding for Planned Parenthood
so maybe programs like this they would
be in support of too it's it's generally
not the people on the ground but rather
the representatives and in this case the
president that's why you have to make
your feelings known to your
representatives there have to be
electoral repercussions for Trump if he
passes a health insurance plan that
spikes premium costs for seniors up to
five times
if Trump cancels meals on wheels again
mostly for seniors if Trump D funds WIC
there have to be repercussions for this
and I'm sad too I guess have to admit
the the probable reality that some
people will never hear about this some
people will and won't care and some
people will and we'll find a way to
blame Obama or Democrats
it is a sad time folks it is very very
sad to call the car buying process
stressful is an understatement for many
people that I know and today's sponsor
my hopscotch comm actually helps you buy
a car but removes many of those
anxiety-producing aspects of it they
will find the right car for
you they will negotiate the price the
trade-in financing even warranties if
you want so that you don't have to and
if you're not thrilled with their
services you have a money-back guarantee
from my hopscotch comm check it out and
save 10% off using the promo code David
at my hopscotch comm try it you'll not
want to buy a car without them because
it will be such a better experience get
rid of the anxiety inducing nonsense of
buying a car my hopscotch comm promo
code David